[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host down sake on
really excited to be talking about
street life we're gonna be talking about
humanizing other people we have with us
juju julius and come out of the shell
brother thanks I appreciate it
so juju I'm really excited we met in ad
right there and Stevenson Street right
in the back between right there on on
market but like it's right just past
Market Street it's right next to Market
Street Stevenson a lie right between
sixth and seventh and and there's a if
there's a community back there and you
know when we were back there we were
talking to you or talking some other
people and it was really nice to just
get to know other people back there and
just to you know talk to you about your
life even for an extended period of time
rather than just walking by each other
yeah now I wanna and so since then we've
kept in touch and and we've we've we've
been wanting to sit down together so now
it's good we get to sit down together
juju I want to ask you about your life I
want to hear and I want to express
express this this your what you're gonna
teach people about like who you are
where you came from to to other people
so we can try and you know really
humanize the conversation
juju you're born in Fairfield California
7:07 and you know you know you were born
you were born to both mom and dad were
around no I never knew my dad I lived my
mom up until I think I was like four or
five I
my half-sisters grandparents got custody
of me and I stayed with a muppet oh I
was about a little 11 almost 12
why did you mom stop taking care uh my
mom was you know heavy on drugs you know
I mean doing what she does and I guess I
was she wasn't suitable as a mother at a
time but she's more than a mother than
me so I don't know like I really ever I
was told lies my whole life about what
business my my my real side of my family
and I believed it up until I was 18 so
like and I just asked they don't really
know my family like that because my like
tribulations I guess yeah we were you
hiding
like what was why were you why why'd you
decide to lie about what happened with
your family no not lie I was told lies
oh you're told lies yeah yeah you told
lies by yours
you're your half-sister yeah my other
side of my family like I guess without
saying what were they saying my mom was
a job you civ on those were lies I mean
yeah my mommy for me was just another
another woman surviving out here in the
streets and I mean like these streets
were here before me they were here
before her yeah and you can meet us like
sometimes you can't avoid them I mean
like as much as you wanted to try you
for me like just to be like it on the
other side what people like to say no
nor me you know I mean like yeah it's
it's I don't know like that's my home
you know that's my mom
yeah I mean like I really don't know her
like I don't know if I'm barely know my
mom at all I only met her a few times
and a little bit I have she's been my
best friend she has been is what you see
you've met her now throughout your life
again you went I probably haven't seen
her like twice since I got taken from
her and it was never more than a couple
days I talked to her all the time on the
phone
she tells me she loves me I have a
little brother and sister I haven't met
a little North Carolina over there and
well she moved to North Carolina
yeah my mom's amazing woman she got a
job she has two kids or two more kids
working a new Anu with the new know what
she's doing all by yourself Wow
Alberto she was that she was like a cook
she changed my life I'm gonna change my
life around
yeah can we give the shout out a shout
out and say no because we should also
get it try to give a chance to I mean
would you like to see each other
she didn't North Carolina right trying
to get to see mama I've been trying to
get back there forever
every time I got it but only thing that
always holds me these are the little
things they do is probation parole or
I'll have the money and then something
to happen to me I go go back to jail I
mean like but will create a semi already
inspired to you are looking we can
create a separate fund because we have
there are some people that want that are
trying to help collaborate with what
we're doing and fund some of the like
some of the interviews that we have to
travel to to go do so it would be
interesting to create like a 500 dollar
fund for you to go see your mom cool
yeah and see how many people we're gonna
put that with $500 what are you gonna do
put them on the [ __ ] bus saying yeah
but you know wouldn't you you living in
200 oh no you know what you cost to get
to North Carolina and a bag little
spending money buy a [ __ ] sandwich
come on 500 bucks ha ha Ron you you know
what if you shoot too high people might
not contribute to it so I'm trying to be
as you know well let's go let's go on
with the show and let's let's talk about
that later
that's a very interesting we're gonna
put a link in the bio for you guys to
check out it will make a little comment
we'll make a call we'll start aiming to
make a contribution to doing this
because that's a that's a really good
idea for people that like like what what
were you describing right now this is
third time going to be able to see your
mom
so yeah and like I have a little sister
that I'd never met and where she she in
North Carolina she wasn't my mom so now
what why don't you tell us a bit more
about you know when you're growing up
you actually ended up passing more time
with your your half sisters grandparents
yeah so thanks to that I got a son of my
grave I'm in a kind of a memory I got
took like around Easter time at school I
was a kid a garden in school and some of
those marshals took me and I put me on
an airplane and like my grandparents I
love him to death you know I mean like I
love love him straight to death but it's
just like the lies and stuff you can
read and I can never get answers to it
like when I was 11 my grandma had a
really bad stroke and she went from
being like I was a everyone called me
grandma's boy when I was a little and
like only person that you thought would
be her so that was like my best friend
and she had a really bad stroke so she
went from being my grandma mom best
friend whatever you want to call it tib
unit like a three-year-old child so like
like that's when I started really acting
up in school and stuff and I could put a
lot of stress on my grandfather like his
heart and I mean and basically I guess
he had a heart attack his heart exploded
in his chest and like I said my grandma
she went from being an adult to a
three-year-old so like if you just have
experience with toddlers toddlers like
to cry wolf a lot and I guess my
grandma's actually always screamed for
help all the time but this time she
really needed help and I let her scream
for like two hours
whoa I'm not gonna lie I was I don't
know what it was my problem but I
finally decided to go see what my
grandpa's I like what is he like what's
going on he like my favorite TV shows on
and I go into the room and she's
standing up which is weird because she
was in a wheelchair she's standing up
and she's pointing on inside the bed and
I was 11 years old and I've been around
the corner of the bed my grandfather was
laid out took his last breath right in
front of me
and I called nine one up the ambulance
came they made me sit in the front yard
and put a blanket over me so I didn't
see everything coming I like him coming
out and how old were you eleven eleven
right that was my first experience with
seeing something like that and I waited
at my neighbor's house - my dad got off
work my dad got off or my sister's dad
really he's my my stepdad and he got off
work he went to hospital and they told
me he was gone from there
I went from like extended family members
houses even me like I acted up I didn't
know how to act I mean I just rebelled
against everything I try to find my
grandma I guess in other girls
it was kind of weird but I mean but I
like not like some weirdo stuff but no
that's not weird that's what you know
most part that love oh yeah yeah
whatever the love you knew brewing
growing up so I got kicked out of family
members houses for most the time over a
girl or something and or riding my
skateboard and like that's my weakness
so skateboards and she so my dad we need
to see your eyes so I finally go back to
my dad's house with my now I'm happy
you know I'm juice you know I mean like
living my grandparents anything I want
it you know me I could anything I wanted
to state my mind to or do that make sure
I do it like I want to skate with her
give me a skateboard I want a bike to
give me a bike if I want dirtbike to
give me their bike so that was my second
hobby I wrote dirt bikes really ride
their bikes really well and like so I'm
with my dad cool
my dad Mary's just like mail-order bride
from the Philippines and she does not
like kids at all yeah you couldn't just
be with your your grandma you she didn't
as I put her in a nursing home I learned
in nursing yeah
take care because she's in wheelchair
because she had a stroke she had a
stroke yeah and so I don't even know
she's still alive
I'm a senior since a while since I was
like 14 those last time I seen her and
she was in Fairfield and your dad is in
Fairfield my dad moved to the
Philippines he quit his job at the
prison back into a prison and went to
the Philippine and what did you do at
that time I got put in foster care to
foster care I was at 14 you said no
around 12 is all around the time when
grandpa died tricked around 12 years old
Wow
seventh grade was my first year in
foster care no one else left it in the
family to take care of nope yeah no I
ever liked the people who did I [ __ ]
it up I mean like I was always told like
on the real side of my family when I
finally went there I like I was raised
up to hate that side of the family so
like I would like everything they said I
would think it would be like bad for me
so I ruins a couple of other
relationships which I kind of regret but
like I still care about me I know they
do but there's just so much that people
could do and push you so far until they
could have to be like I'm cooling in
watch the hands of you yeah so when
you're when you're 12 in your and you're
put into foster care what what does that
feel like what is that like that day was
probably the second worst day of my life
after my grandfather died my dad
basically told me my sister that we had
won had to go to stay with my mom and
the other one I just was stay out here
with him or stay out here gonna stay
with him but we we mean my son took it
as with him like I told you before my I
was raised up on lies about my mom and
dad so I mean about my like mom and my
real side of my family so my sister
being the older one said she would go
out there and I'll stay out here and one
day my dad was just like we're going to
McDonald's with all my stuff in the car
and we drove past McDonald's and he
dropped me off at the police station
it was like January 4th
what the [ __ ] yeah so here we are let's
talk about let's talk about right the
day that was the day juju was born holy
[ __ ] was your birth name birth name is
Julius Julius yeah yeah and and what the
[ __ ] at 12:00 with your stuff being
dropped off at the station yeah what
yeah station and often does this happen
to kids around the world stuff some
people don't even get that lucky good
job of a police station some people get
dropped off as do sodality they don't
even get the chance to hit foster care
on the web somebody like or whatever not
to make light of the situation but
whatever wherever you are in the world
you know there's this people yeah it's
so far so good
Julius that's all I'm saying because
here we are today you're right
that's that's the way the way I look at
it you know whatever take to operations
and I'm black you know I mean I'm
african-american and it's out here in
these streets she's proud I blacked out
I wish we could copy write some James
Brown music here I wonder how James
Brown had it growing up you know
yeah but living in the streets like it
be an african-american a lot of kids
don't make it to see 21 he's act like
mother brother recipes daddy wobbler he
didn't make it at Ellen he made it Toby
was 20 years old and all he did was just
try to go give my sister some weed but
he what happened to him he got shot by
Bank of a police department because they
said he used his car as a weapon towards
him after they called a successful pit
maneuver over the radio so if it was a
police call successful people move over
the radio with the car disabled yeah I
guess it my brother just turned the car
back on charge that way they try to say
use the car as weapon a random four
anybody knows my little brother he was
just trying to get away yeah you know I
mean like he didn't deserve to die and
but that's all done I mean somehow Union
you learned about that how older even
you know how those doses last year that
was last year yeah holy [ __ ] okay let's
let's go back that's nice to see these
types of so any any time someone that
passes a lot of time with humans we've
we've had we've had a good amount of
psychologists psychiatrists people that
have studied anthropologists humans for
thousands of humans tens of thousands of
humans and land like their life's and so
what what people usually call these
moments you know traumatic moments and
these moments end up they changed the
actual structure of our brain to reflect
on these moments of trauma and it's
actually really difficult to be when you
have so many stacked moments been
dropped off by your dad your younger
brother like all this type of stuff
stacks up and it makes it really
difficult to dig oneself out of the hole
unless they have a good amount of
support systems around them to help them
so all right so take us back to 12 what
is it yeah why is this the second worst
day of your life
because it I don't know what it was like
to go from in foster care and stuff like
I got just like I don't even know what
foster care was yeah I mean like so like
I went from living like I guess from
rags to a normal life you know I mean my
mind you might might have my
grandparents they're white like they're
the white messages half black half white
so I lived I grew up like my kids the
grandparents we were talking about
earlier our wife yes okay we should have
established that a long time ago as
shown and so icing so like if people
stare typical day like okay black kids
are raised here you for me they all five
kids live in one bedroom in this net
white kids they all have their own
bedroom and they get million presents
for Christmas you know I mean like
that's just how this is how the world is
I don't know why but it is
and like so basically I was raised from
white to black hell if it looks so like
I lived like best about 406 in a way so
I went to having anything in anything to
having nothing mm-hmm and it sucks you
know I mean it sucks yeah I had a share
room hand-me-down clothes
I couldn't eat my favorite food that I
want it and I mean like what's that yeah
back then it was a tuna casserole for
some reason I don't know why I love to
the capsules I'm so good to be or like
tuna melts it hello you can relive there
so I couldn't even be like I couldn't
have whatever I wanted no I mean
Christmases you know I mean like I don't
have nobody
Christmases then on the weekends I
didn't have I couldn't go home to my
family
and I mean like I got thrown full head
on in foster care I mean like but I
learned quick I mean I learn quicker
fighting between fighting for my stuff
oh yeah what did you learn
didn't you learn you learn how to fight
not me I don't how to survive I had to I
had to grow up quick
what was the reasons why year to learn
how to fight like what goes on because
you like say I get a cool little chain
like this you know I mean like that's
cool you know I mean like and then I go
to sleep and I wake up in his gun he'll
be like I don't know what happened to it
there's only five people in the room
yeah so like you learn how to fight you
know how to survive stand up for
yourself I want to say you learned how
to be a man for me I never had nobody to
teach me how to be a man teach myself
how to be a man yeah and I'm still
learning to this day boy do what he can
a man does what he wants you for me so I
will start experience with drugs I start
smoking weed affairs we cigarettes to
ecstasy pills to cocaine I mean how old
was this this is it's from 12 to now so
you know Mean Girls experiencing girls
never go wrong with that and then
learning all of this yeah so like going
from not having a family to a family
like that's all you want
juju what do you want now what woody
what do you what do you want now out of
life woody woody woody we want to do how
old do you again look I just want to be
content I mean I don't want to be rich
content [ __ ] that there's no [ __ ]
content I'm done yeah cuz if your
continued there's that yeah well content
you have to get content in the chaos and
what are you gonna do how are you gonna
you know better yourself within this
chaos you know I hear you talking a lot
about you know where you've been where
are you coming from why you do the
things you do but once you understand
that my I'm more interested in what do
you want what are we gonna do now what
are we gonna do about why we're having
you here on the show I know I'm saying
but we only have one hour okay
we're great just slow down let's get
there together if we have to do another
episode we will just slow down a bit we
have some things to cover along the way
juju when did you get out of foster care
mentally or physically give us both and
why is there basically I left foster
care when I was 14 years old
I've been on the streets ever since I
learned how to survive I learn how to
eat I learned how to feed myself at 14
14 years old when she ran away from
every foster home they try to put me in
they catch me that put me back in a
different classroom I'll leave and why
why was because you the freedom was it
the free it's not the freedom uh pain
I guess like I got something back
explain it like well like whoa I would
like how do you do that like how do you
take care how do you take kids away from
everything that they own you know I own
like no you know I mean everything that
you know everything that you believe in
everything all the love all everything
and then put them in in some random-ass
people's houses a lot of people don't
even give a [ __ ] about you excuse me for
cousin know you can cost you I mean like
they don't give a [ __ ] about you I mean
like I've experienced I probably had
three good foster families ever ever in
my entire life I've been over like 48 of
them interesting and why don't you stay
with any of why cuz either some type of
argument or me getting in trouble like
I'm so used to once I get in trouble I
get to the way you know I mean like it's
all interesting because so like in
trouble you'll back to the foster yeah
or like they take me away or they put me
away or so now so now it's to the point
like I'm a hurt I'm gonna just ruin it
before I if you're mad if I get hurt
even like deeper yeah so like I'll push
people away that would be my one thing I
push people away and I try not now I try
to keep everybody near me and now it
just seems like I'm so natural pushing
people away
I just pitch people away on an accident
well stuff it's a brand-new people every
time trying to come into your life and
how do they know anything about you it's
and how do you know anything about them
this is a very hard stuff - yeah right
sync up on the same wavelength and live
together so okay so then you're passing
time now more on the streets and this is
you went through 48 different operating
rooms somebody one day somebody a couple
weeks long as I was saying a classroom
was seven months now was my first foster
home damn and they have five kids in a
room sometimes you know sometimes up to
live in this hand-me-down clothes and
whatever food they serve you Christmas
presents you get like people who they
got programs like like like foster
foster dream and stuff like that they
they come through like casa workers case
people like
big sisters and like the phosphor may
don't buy you presents you know I mean
crystal comes to everybody those
presents nobody I can't remember the
last time I ever had a Christmas and
maybe in jail with a snicker bar or
something we got one coming up it would
be good to essentially to fundraising
get some presents out yeah this is good
this is this is very interesting
holidays no I mean like chickens reading
and stuff like that
can't remember last time Halloween cost
me there I mean so but juju when when
was it that you see your your on your on
your going to the streets you're
spending more of your time on the
streets you went through when did you
stop the 48th foster home when was that
last when I was in I was 17 17 and so
you're passing time now now you're
around 17 you're where are you living
now I was living too clearly at
California where collect California
solar clearly Oh Clear Lake so I went
out to Clear Lake my father father
father a social worker he's I'm seeing
you how the far away so you could just
so took one thing I tend to do is I
could I could go anywhere in this world
I guarantee I can make a best friend and
within 24 hours if that yes so so that's
one thing I did do like so they sent me
to Clear Lake and I like I ride
skateboards I mean so the first day
there I go to skate park and I meet
these dudes I'm like you know what do
some we did score score somebody if I
can they're like oh yeah right here he
come to my mom and like I start talking
to their mom and they're like oh you
could come live with us
so like I live in a trailer out there in
Clear Lake I got I got a RV like on the
side of my friend's house for like a
year and then I moved back out here
because living my best friend and 2 SF
know about Fairfield yeah soon then
you're 18 18 and then I caught my first
case as an adult then I went to jail got
out what was your first case first case
I bought I actually bought a stolen car
off somebody
and I bought it like 300 bucks yeah and
I had a flag two weeks and finally his
compost pulled me over because I did at
the car matched a stolen car something
that popped up and I took me to jail for
receiving stolen property well that's
that see that type of a jailing doesn't
make sense how would you know that the
car was stolen you have to go do
research and figure out what are stolen
first I'm black I'm black male in
America yeah of course that car is
stolen even if I even if I bought that
car from a lot I'm getting pulled over
to that car stolen you know I mean like
it's a stereotypical news I guess yeah
but so I get caught here too if I was
white and I said that they would
probably side and release me and let me
go to me to jail for three days and from
there cut another case burglary that's
my star bright like I learned how to
break into things I learned how to steal
things that was survive to survive and I
mean what were you breaking into and
stealing to survive houses you know cars
buildings anything that wasn't bolted
down okay so but I'm not proud of it you
know I mean like Halloween me too I mean
I seen there I would kill for a
nine-to-five I mean but like yeah as you
guys can't tell like 90 I'm about 80% of
my buddies tattooed I mean I got we do
you have one on you neck cuz that's like
the clincher that's when you you know my
face I mean my hands so that's actually
a major hiring now nowadays though like
it's cool I mean it's just
nowadays you like tattoos that's the
thing I mean like everybody's got
tattoos so like it's cool you have
tattoos now well San Francisco LA New
York these places will still yeah but
yeah you're like in the middle of
nowhere they'll they'll be two
completely different and actually the
way that you were describing when when
when you're driving on the street if
you're in you know if you're in
somewhere that is more of a metropolis
area you're more likely to get loved
than you are to get hate if you're in
the middle of nowhere in the US you can
get a lot
and there have been there's been many
documented instances of what you're
describing and that's some [ __ ] and
we got to get through that as soon as
possible because people are their
livelihoods are at risk like your
younger brother in that case so so when
did you move to SF from Fairfield
alright so I moved from SF so like my
best friend
my best friend is Tyrone and we're not
even that cool I mean like I color my
sister she's like the only real family
I've had since like my grandparents I
mean my name's Shawna ray
she's from Pacifica California and I
didn't come out here to tell like a
couple of years like I've only been in
Frisco living out here for a year
well a year now but I got stayed out
here previously for like six months but
that's to my sister and she she brought
me out here my my one of my little
brothers I called that's probably out
for him right now
Sean he does held a fentanyl and stuff
there if I mean it my bad with Matt
blast him on there but what's fentanyl
that no I don't know what the [ __ ] it is
it's like a thousand times worse than
heroin
it's what kills that's what all these
ambulances out here that's what killed
us a lot of these kids I hear these days
well if I mean he is it's a
pharmaceutical killed Michael Jackson oh
[ __ ] yeah
fentanyl that's the new thing that's the
new thing fentanyl huh that we need to
be careful of Ron can you pull up if
your little up the NDI Ron if you have a
pillow that's it and you put an air duct
it in a room for people at least I were
like three they say they say 30 out of
those hundred people who died well 30
out of the hundred will die in a
fentanyl
yeah no vent fentanyl fentanyl fentanyl
common brands dura jessic services it
can treat severe pain it's a narcotic
called substance apparent high risk for
addiction and dependence can cause
respiratory distress and death when
taken in high doses or when combined
with other substances especially alcohol
Wow yeah and so it's a pain relief you
shoot it whatever it like it's a high
commodity out here right now
kind of hate it you know because I know
you've tried it I've never once tried
but now you see it's taking its toll on
streets people are dying I used to sell
it I mean all right
this medication used to help relieve
severe ongoing pain belongs to a class
of drugs known as opioids yeah yeah it's
the strongest opiate in the world it is
the strongest opiate fences a thousand
times it's like a hundred times a heroin
times a I mean so Wow um holy [ __ ]
okay so soon so now tell us where were
you at why are you so like that's if you
know my him oh you know I mean police
whoever people are treated as among men
right like you know my 3d mobile if you
did if you know my mo like I sell drugs
so that's like that's why I started
coming to fist it was over drugs push
the wrong button I'm sorry I'd be a
mistake
no yeah oh wait yeah it's gone it's gone
okay so like Mia Shawn just so happened
to be messing with the same girl but the
girl told both of us
no he's like my brother you know me so
that's how being hit bit but I met the
girl through my sister and so I started
hanging out with Shawn and I broke my
parole sent me to a program in Oakland
and it just right next to Bart so I
figured you can just parts of ten
minutes away you know I mean if that's
what feels like at least and so I'll
just hop on Bart now coming out here so
I don't know anybody from Mike from Mike
this part of the Bay Area and like I
just I want to get close to you I'll be
close to you forever like even if you
even if you like you like stab me in the
back a thousand times I'll still you can
be like I'll always forgive you
so like me and Sean we've always been
hella close and well since we met and I
just seen how it is out here so I like I
try to make a difference I don't know
why I don't know what made me want to
make a difference but like it was just
different from seeing people like
growing up homeless where I live
and your coming out here it's like the
end of day it's all the same community
everybody knows how to respect each
other everybody knows how to you look
out for each other like if you need
anything no means so tell us about more
of this what are these sort of
etiquettes that happened when did you
come out to the SF uh when I became like
to move and live out here homeless yeah
about a year ago a year ago now so
you're 25 when he did that what what
happened between 20 and 25 before we get
to more about 20 or 25 I went to prison
it gave me eight years eight months for
what burglary possession of sales
possession of firearm all those jumped
up to like a high all the different
things I did 5 years 2 months 21 days on
it you did 5 years fire through much 21
days but let me backtrack a little bit
when I was 12
like what I was saying um I always
looked for a family so what made me go
just heavy into the streets is I went
looking for that family in the streets
yeah I got clipped up with somebody I'm
not gonna med class what I got kicked up
clicked up with but if you know me you
know what it is and I got clicked up you
know I mean and what does being clicked
up mean I join the game you join a game
ok ok I want to say J again I trying to
struggle a movement clicked up that's
what they call it good right you get rad
with the nomenclature join I put my life
sigh my life to devil basically and I
joined for all the wrong reasons but I
stayed for all the right reasons I mean
cuz it's what I believe in BAM family I
mean like yeah it's a it's it's that
that family I never had and I mean like
my kids are gonna grow up to not my mom
and dad as grandparents probably some
random people that I call my mom and dad
you know I mean like I got a dad up I
got a mom and dad we your brothers I
want to say that you you you looking for
a family I'll just die you know we're
all interconnected in one way or another
we can't lose sight of that and just
yeah I mean I'm your brother dude you
you know we're wishing you the best of
luck if I your situation is you you know
you're looking for some certain content
in life let's let's see what we can do
to make that happen because I personally
you know don't do enough for any
movement of you know certain
marginalized communities so let's go
yeah Gigi let's continue the
conversation I spent more of my life
behind the walls I feel like then I have
on the streets this hallway actually was
my first Halloween like almost eight
years out on the streets yeah you know I
just spent about myself walking around I
don't know like I guess I don't know I
don't you just those those see you gave
me that understanding now that I think a
lot of times we end up when you grew up
in a situation would that didn't have
that immediate love and that immediate
family and that's a crucial part of
nurturing children into the world is for
them to have love and family and like
you said also resources and tools for
you to be able to figure out what you
love and care about and so then you went
out looking for love and you were
looking for it in part and like a girl
you were looking for it and uh you know
in in a group of people getting clicked
up that that kind of stuff I wonder how
often that happens and I mean and how to
how to build that loving
culture to make it so that we don't go
into burglaries and go into the loops of
crime that and the people for five years
behind bars when but isn't that part of
the economy if you go trying to make
people better
aren't you messing up with a party so
which how will you know I'm leaving the
economy around the economy's no longer
going to be about prisons and about the
[ __ ] nonsense it's going to be about
more health and wellness and
sustainability and love and that type of
stuff so the economy is totally shifting
right now in that dress
so we're not even to talk about I'm was
just I was just just experiencing myself
it's totally going in that direction
collapse of empire all right so all
right so now we're we're talking my
family were talking about lover time
these things now tell us about this you
know you were in for five years it's a
[ __ ] that's [ __ ] I was in for four
months and I thought that was [ __ ] it
forever I did being in four days in
Mitchell South Dakota the jail being in
there is like tell us about what it was
like for you that's why I learn how to
be a man at I mean
sucks Maji says prison brothels turned a
man out of a lunar year yeah but like
you learn how you like like I'm a wild
wild I mean like hyper like to have fun
I like to make jokes like in there you
gotta learn how to humble yourself you
gotta learn how to conduct yourself
especially being part of what I'm part
of you know I mean like you got a you
got a you got to be some sometimes you
be somebody you're not
mm-hmm and you gotta learn how to
survive you ever learn how to putting on
the front
yeah the eminence front yes put on it's
put on sometimes people forget you know
that song by the Who am I getting myself
there you know that one eminence front
Yeah right on continue yeah then you got
a for me like to show another man
respect they live with an like thousand
other men no I mean on a bunk bed you
know I mean like hey you gotta learn how
to you know how to show respect people
yes I mean like that comes to the
visiting you like when we visit a room
like they'll stand up guy's wife and I
mean you learn how to clean you know
like you're not gonna live in a dirty
jail cell yeah so like you learned how
to you familiar how survive and then
being a grown-ass man and behind prisons
like nine times that ten-year girls not
gonna stay I think if I get girls are
gonna stay so then you better learn how
to work so you can learn how to survive
and eat yeah i mean so like i never was
taught that because I was too busy
running around
and doing whatever but I learned a lot
of stuff I learned in prison
I used to normal day life and I feel
like it keeps me keeps me sane and keeps
me keeps me there
you know I mean but like I'm relaxed
can't stay out of jail so what was what
were some of the resources that you had
there they give you access to library
access to exercise access yeah that's
one thing that I could tell you I didn't
when I was in jail every time I'm in
jail I don't just sit there I don't sit
there and I don't watch TV I don't I
didn't play games all day and I mean
like I sit there I work out I come home
super healthy every time I read I've
read over thousands of books I love to
read yeah what's your favorite stuff to
read I like action adventure right now
yeah I was kind of into like like what
we're doing right now have you read the
child called it that's my favorite
called it that's my favorite book I
recommend you guys read that if you have
any kids that are in foster care they
read it got by Dave pilzer and basically
like his life is exactly what almost
exactly like what happened to me and now
it's like a foster story yeah it's like
a bus story I called it his mom was so
abusive to him like he'll abusive stab
to have a stuff and I mean and I don't
know it's just my life I know you have
that's right questions I could go on and
on from this is what this is what we're
trying to do we're trying to learn more
about about you and what happened here
so I wasn't always homeless told totally
totally your story is so so it's just
super interesting and this is it now how
many other people have stories along
this and okay now okay let's go let's go
to some of the newer node this last year
you got out of prison yes and that was
in California California high desert
high desert okay three okay three so
what what is the level is that before
would be the highest level three or four
of the highest they got no hands hands
on policy what is that basically if you
want to get into an issue it's going to
be a riot and everybody's been stabbed
so I think the the as in the jail
officers are going to prison office no
jail officers are just gonna let it go
out for like 30 40 minutes and then
they're gonna come out the black guns
and start laying [ __ ] down yeah and it's
they let you fight for Wow before they
break it up is that how they are usually
won't break it up they let it finish out
it gets too big there's starting people
teargas beanbag guns yeah my first day
in prison or first-line mainline South
siders were doing a removal and like
this dude would not stop stabbing this
dudes like you tell the dude was it was
dead it was over with and like he
wouldn't stop stopping him so they do it
in the tower like everywhere you go it
says no warning shots stay behind the
line no warning shots
yeah no warning shots Jesus why don't I
remember something else there instead of
a piece of tape no one shots means like
if they tell you to get down and the
yard Goes Down you could get down but
like so like if they have to put those
guns out they're not shooting I gotta
warn you yeah they're just shooting the
kill he says I've seen this I've never
heard a grown man scream how I heard him
scream
this fool got shot with a mini 14 and it
blew his whole hip off and he did like a
540 oh and like like that's when I knew
it was real I mean like I knew it was
real my second month a mainline yard
went up 300 man riot that's fine that's
when I really knew what if I was like
I'm really here right now yeah I mean
I'm here for five [ __ ] years yeah so
I was really puzzling to be there for
four I got eight what half and I want to
catch him a bit of time yeah I'm
cellphones not means smoking weed if I
can how the [ __ ] you think it's
cellphone for the Cubs 30 cops you know
I mean what the the what how did yeah
how does that have work how do you think
I don't know [ __ ] in there anything you
say about a fourth
yeah the right amount of people anybody
do anything for a dollar you know I mean
so just you just got to find the right
crap [ __ ] I mean everywhere is
corrupt down to the White House yeah
so they're trying to talk about all
these programs of trying to send us and
that was and they're all called FEMA
camps you know I mean like you're
sentenced to a Fema camp that's
basically a prison inside of a prison
what does you do you know a few a stands
for FEMA I don't know
Federal Emergency Management yeah is
that is that yeah yeah but it's like
population can population control
let's see Fema camp of course you've
heard of the FEMA cam I thought it was
of course you've heard those FEMA camps
yeah Allen I thought it was like some
Tweaker like oh they're gonna put in
like it's not like that shit's really
happening right now so it's basically no
FEMA's u.s. little emergency management
agency yeah basically is legal slavery
or whatever is planning to imprison US
citizens in concentration camps yep this
is typically described as following the
imposition of martial law in the United
States after a major disaster or crisis
suspected distance will be imprisoned
large number of US students will be in
prison for the purposes of extermination
is a new world all accomplished
Holocaust publish and control about
FEMA's unites his government agency
tasked with effective management of
major emergencies within the country our
skilled disaster such as nuclear war so
so you're so you're seeing there FEMA
camps inside of Prisons no this famous
cancer site is right now I gotta what
navigation Center all that stuff you
know I mean like I got police or
arresting homeless people and like
sending them to these programs
like a Fema camp basically that's they
program means FEMA I guess in a way like
they were trying to like it like if you
don't go to a program if you're homeless
like they're gonna send you to jail
what's the program which I don't know
yeah it's like I got the navigation
Center Hellfire 360 navigation Center
they call it a navigation Center yes
it's like a dorms with people but like
you could leave there but now like know
how when Donald Trump started kidnapping
the kids yes just like that
that's what they were said put in
prisons kids including immigrants right
yeah so didn't know that is this a
program that's available to you yeah I
knew on the streets I mean yeah into it
you are right yeah yeah yeah well so
there's it so there's these navigation
centers so there's but then but then if
if if people are given the option to go
to these places usually they can find
what a place to live they can find a job
yeah that's a like I don't know out like
really out here how it is like I think
it's just a place for them to live and
get off the streets and sleep you know
me have a place to go but they say like
they're opposed to give you in the
housing they got like these new housing
things and stuff like that but like
that's really my only problem like I
know I know since I've I've done it you
know I mean like I wasn't always like
this
I mean like I was always in the streets
but like I wasn't always heading on in
the streets like how I am now
mmm it's like they say after a certain
amount of days they'll give you an
apartment and stuff like that and but I
don't know a lot of people don't make it
they go there they get high I say as I
said those programs right now worse than
the food's programs are worse than the
streets I say the programs are worse in
the streets right now but then why do
you want to go into one because I I'm
not trying to go there for the street
part of it I'm trying to go there for
the actual benefits of it and I mean
like you've been in these rates 26 years
of my life
over it I'm over it and I mean like
there's no way there's no reason I
should be 26 and tired I mean like 26
and thriving yeah not thriving I'm tired
tired no that's what's at 26 robbery
then Tony sick until hired you wanna be
26 and thrive he's driving I wanted you
for me like I know it's like stand on
the black you fill me with a mouth full
of spit is you know I mean I was like to
hold a pistol I know it's like them
layers they lay people down I know this
like to do everything then it woopsie me
to behind those walls you know I mean
everything I know it's like to be part
of the urban life I guess you want to
call it and I also know what it's like
to be part of the normal life the normal
American citizen I guess what people
want to say yeah I'm tired tired of
sticking me stand in alleys
I'm tired of beating people up to that
they still [ __ ] some tin foil or some
[ __ ] even me I'm a backpack okay or and
I'm tired of you for me like all the
stupid-ass [ __ ] [ __ ] no I mean like I've
lost almost everything one of my best
friends from the streets and I'm
surprised I didn't go before them I mean
so that's yeah I lost my wife to the
streets
I lost my daughters to the streets yeah
I've lost everything to the streets cars
apartments shoes for me I thought
America materialistic stuff but I mean
like so what when did you get married
very good I had a kid apparently I have
another one too
I don't know how that's gonna go I guess
nine years ago is the first one thanks
Ron so nine years ago
yeah so and how did how did that happen
that was back in that was austere okay
yeah that was just one random night on
ecstasy yeah that's I just found out
about her about a week ago and my my
daughter Tatiana she I found out about
her when I got out of prison yeah
what happened what happened with her
Gianna yeah you know telling Nicole my
best friend she's like I saved my life
like I was really [ __ ] up and
depressed and the most
and everything I meant I met Tiana was
just for her mom Tori she basically
pulled me out of my depression I tried
to kill myself twice
I was thinking anyway you for me that to
get away from my life and I mean like my
past in my future and this little girl
just brought the world I don't know like
she would not she wouldn't leave me
alone that's what it was I would scream
and dad I didn't tell me for me like
anytime I talk to you sit there Pat it
unless he I mean like she's but the
streets took her to you know I mean like
being homeless stuff you learned how to
make homeless family and people around
you you for me and some people ain't all
right in the head some people are like
jealous like I gonna be jealous of a
four-year-old you know I mean so one day
she quit miss she went with her grandpa
and I don't really want to get in
details about our camera but somebody
put hands on my daughter and she got to
away and I don't know it just it was
what it was sucked so that made me and
my girl break up and we just went our
separate ways she was supposed to get
her back I couldn't stay a jail I got
always run that's my that's my biggest
pet peeve is going into jail that's my
downfall and that's from either because
they I can't I don't have no money to
catch it go to catch the bus to Vallejo
to see my parole well I just don't check
in he's always checking in I don't
really catch cases like that
yeah anymore and interesting so go even
just going and checking in itself if I'm
tough going back to jail soon right now
because it like I haven't been to
Vallejo
I'm a pro he told me go back to a
program I didn't go to it all because of
a girl me her broke up so that made me
want to go to probation and start asking
about these programs she finally does
the record she doesn't referral for the
program and I just don't go like I just
like I go like I try I called my left
messages no one called let me back so
like after if I feel like no one cares
about me then why should I cover myself
I mean why why why should I go do that
so I just got a that's why should go
right after this I sleep so in so as you
as you're talking about this to to me
when what is nuts is that you're trying
to calculate how to go and check in to
to parole in meanwhile you're also
trying to go to the navigation yeah I
mean that they're working that my
probation work together it's it's it's
more I'm trying to be I'm trying to
still be in the streets and still do the
right thing yeah because that's just
what I'm used to is the streets but
that's what I want is is that it's doing
the right thing I don't want to be out
here cold every night I don't want to be
out here wearing the same outfit for
three or four days I don't want to go
steal from stores be I don't want to go
yeah I don't want to be hot in an alley
nodded off on drugs you can be like I
don't want to I don't want them to that
I mean I just want to be at home if you
don't want to go to work to and from
work for me don't work he's on the table
and just come home you know I mean what
do you need to do that but my only
problem is really is stable and stable
living it's so hard to become a stable
living like because right now like you
said you try and go get an employment
and you have the tattoos what's the
thing that's holding you back from
getting that which of the record was
record and I mean a felonies
really anything school let me I dropped
out of school when I was 16 years old to
ride skateboards
a thousand come professional prison stop
that but you can you can do a task at a
job perfectly thought to do anything up
yeah my heart to is just not having a
credential it's not having a high school
diploma it's not having a stable housing
like right now I don't have an ID card
I'll have a Social Security card I don't
have anything well then I got right now
is a quarter in my pocket a bike with a
flat tire it's a $9 necklace and 200
shoes
I mean Ana foments gonna get shut off
soon because I can't pay for the bill I
mean like I don't know I shouldn't even
really be here right now cuz it's gonna
be like I don't know what if it may have
an eight today I woke up late and I mean
[ __ ] I can't I saw I don't have no
money to pay for my my room so I'll
probably be standing outside your office
no I mean like all night little do you
guys know I like I live in a closet
right next door okay you fit me so and
that's probably I mean there's not even
classical a gas room yeah I mean like
and then once that's once I get caught
in there that's breaking and entering
you know I mean so I don't know I don't
know how to change it well I guess we're
aiding and abetting a criminal right I'm
not ready right now
so has so many pieces that are so [ __ ]
I make it so hard to get people out of
the [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah yeah cuz I'm
as you're talking about all the things
that are coming together that make this
happen it's like they're they're there
and they're holding it back there
they're trying to make it so that
society is is is is is a safe place but
at the same time it's holding people
back from being able to like you just
need to [ __ ] live you just need to
get that first job you just need to
stabilize yourself so you can come home
and so you can like you said be content
yeah and there's the to make that
process easier for people is is super
duper important that's how we can
humanize each other I want I want to
talk about some of these misconceptions
before we and this is really important
you were saying earlier that the term
homeless is [ __ ] wack wack you know I
mean I homey you tell us about that
homeless the word homeless in my eyes on
a lot of people's eyes is when you hear
homeless you think of Oh army jacket
army pants big ass duffel bag home
shopping cards probably a tent somewhere
I mean always on drugs like I don't want
to like
then that's like this typical stereotype
of homeless like if you look at me even
right now I bet you for me I feel grimy
nasty if you look at me like I'm up you
feel my pants my shirt everything still
has price tags on it and I mean like you
like you couldn't tell I was homeless
unless I told you I was homeless unless
you see me in this alley chillin and
even then you feed me you couldn't tell
I was homeless
a lot of times when the police come
through here I'm passing out supplies
some people think I work for the Clyde
you okay it's it's homelessness I'm
gonna say I'm homeless I'm just without
home yeah without home homeless homeless
to Mimi's lost that's those people that
aren't ever gonna get back those people
that's in there selling herself shorts
for cigarettes or stand in front of the
stores you for me begging for change you
never seen you beg for anything that's
one thing I learned how to do growing up
is stand on my own two yeah I mean like
interesting so without home yeah just
because I'm just at home you're on your
way to home is what you want it yeah I'm
gonna find a home I'm just without home
you know I mean like eventually you feel
like if I kid senior out and I mean like
I will because I guess I will could be
considering myself homeless you know I
mean like but I'm not eating out the
trash cans you know I mean like I'll go
smoke a bowl of meth before I [ __ ]
eat out of a trash can yeah so it's like
like I use drugs but I'm not a drug
addict you know I mean like my life
doesn't isn't revolved around drugs like
my wife is a revolve around surviving
yeah it's you can be like when I get my
money I don't get my money for myself I
get money for my brother's my sisters
yeah my money for me my mom and my dad
yeah I mean like there's people out here
that I just met that if they want
something just looks just how like like
how they carry their self if I have it
I'll give it to him just recently my
second day out of jail I'm on the bus
and just dude rich I was the one who
dudes out staying with outside he get
he's like gets on the bus shirtless it's
like three o'clock in the morning he has
these EKGs things like I'm like hospital
brace I just got out the hospital he had
no t-shirt I took my shirt off my back
and gave it to him
I took my shoes off my feet and given
the people I know I could get it I know
I could even be like you knew you were
confident in yourself to go get it but
then you could give it to them in that
moment yeah yeah yeah if you're me like
that's a good way to think about giving
that's because you can go we we can go
and find a means here to go and get the
next things that we need to continue
making this so that way we can give what
we have right now to others it's a very
difficult it's a very good way to put it
but it's also extremely difficult it to
put to put into context and be like it'd
be like well why don't you why don't you
just give this entire recording studio
to someone that can't afford a recording
studio why don't you go and and put
together the next pieces for yourself to
be able to go get another recording
studio and that idea is also like well I
don't quite want to do that and so it's
like well like what do you do then like
do I have an extra pair of shoes yeah do
I have an extra shirt [ __ ] yeah I do I
have extra food yeah [ __ ] yeah these are
the things that we can absolutely pass
along right so can't break yourself in
order to help someone else you can't
completely break yourself you can give
parts of your soul yeah yeah and
basically like then around here like I'm
like I don't know of the world like
whoever watches this like I'm pretty
well known around here which sucks you
can be like I'm like but like I sat back
because it like being well known around
here like old enemies and I mean they
can find you easy oh yeah you think
things out right here how do you know oh
I'm his cousin
oh so now somewhat all your cousins here
now walk up is it on pause I'm shot him
dead you know mean like it and it's that
you think that's that's like one of the
downfalls and another one is like the
police you know I mean like if you're
like the police I know you for crimes
it's bad like it's really bad and but oh
no it's like you've been identified
identified you're you're stiff
stereotyped you know I mean
there are another is there another
community that you can go to that makes
you less known that makes it easier for
you to get a job it's for some reason I
feel like I've known everywhere like
everywhere I go I know somebody but like
I hear Frisco like when I lived out here
previous before I had a job my first job
was ever out here I was doing good you
know I mean and I don't know it's like I
feel there's more opportunities out here
yeah
there's way more opportunities out here
especially if I want to do it be
something would be somebody and I mean
like I'm not trying to be the president
but I just want to be somebody exactly
I don't know like we have a little bit
of time left but we do I'll come back
you know I mean I'm an ordained minister
now as a routine I gotta save as a
minister last time I was in jail wait
yes can that get you work that's that
could open stores what I really want
what I really really want to do is I
want to go to juvenile halls I want to
go to schools I want to go to set up
groups at you for me at the community
center I want to like I want to speak to
kids yeah I mean like kids growing up I
can foster care kids are like just
getting those ages they don't know where
they want to be like what groups like
that wouldn't be a rocker they want to
be emo they want to be a gangsta rapper
you know I mean like I could have been
all those men I used to wear skinny
jeans had both my lips Pierce and wear
leather jackets you know I mean he's I
played play guitar play drums no I mean
like and I ride skateboards you want to
help ain't bang guide to use yeah like I
don't prevent them from getting into
trouble yeah like I don't want to I'm
not here I don't want to sit there and
preach to the kids about this now your
life could be this is an app because I
read it in a book I want to let these
kids know like I'm still young for me
like I know what time it is you know I
mean like this if you want to live like
this this is what you're gonna turn out
to be yeah yeah you're gonna have like
be another role for them to to see cuz
usually they have somebody in their
lives of
some sort of relative or influence of
their life saying that if you live like
this is what you would end up being but
then if nothing other person like you
came in and said I have actually lived
those things that they're saying so so
you can make a you can change the
trajectory of your life right now to do
what you want instead of end up in a
trap and this trap that you're talking
about is not it doesn't make it easy to
get out of the trap it's it's yeah the
way you're talking about it is is
changing the way that I think about and
that's really important and I hope it's
changing the way other people are
thinking about it as well I can't I
can't believe that the amount of
dehumanization that goes on in the world
because we do not even know the life
stories of people like yourself or we
say anything about you like you you had
a very clear when you were when you're
when you're born to just your mom and
then you go off to just your
grandparents and then you go to 48
foster care centers and then you go to
the street so you go to prison you have
to serve you have to survive you learn
you learn all these different things
there's so much trauma that's built up
now you just want to just have somewhere
to come home and drop the keys off after
the job and that's not a lot to ask for
it to have a system that helps people do
that and we got to figure out how to do
that it's a global conversation it has
to happen and it's really tough to
figure out where to start but I know a
place to start we're gonna make a
GoFundMe page GoFundMe page for juju and
the links gonna be in the bio and you
can find that link in the bio to the
Juju's GoFundMe page and then we're
gonna we're gonna put together app at
least 500 bucks if not a thousand bucks
we're gonna start by putting that
together for for juju we're gonna see if
we can get you two to mom in North
Carolina you said see if we can get you
to mom also see if we can get juju to
through the navigation Center these are
the things that we gotta we got to do we
got to do these things these are the
little things we can do get you out of
here with that least food at least
at least food and at least whatever else
you need clothing whatever else you need
and you what are you what are your
thoughts what do you think I don't know
I just want like I guess the people out
there to know like like if you look at
me now I mean like a lot of people are
judgmental I mean like if like you hear
oh he was in foster care he just got out
of prison
oh he has a teardrop on his face he has
he wears a hoodie all the time and oh
and he smokes cigarettes like the first
thing you can think of his hoodlum Doug
don't trust him you for me like he's
gonna rob me or or something like that
like like a little bit like that people
know like everything I do out here in
these streets and learn a lot of people
you for me it's not everybody's not bad
everyone's not a bad person but like
were labeled bad people like yeah I'll
be your Superman I mean like if you need
anything like if people need help cross
street old ladies help car Street if you
need a dollar you know I mean like if
somebody's [ __ ] with you you for me
like it to the other people outside
would be like okay you're just guys
beating this guy up for no reason like
no I gotta beat you up nine times of
tunes for a really good reason you know
I mean like and I'm you for me like
we're not bad people out here like just
because people use drugs and stuff like
that people use drugs so run away from
the real world because it's something
that happened to him the tragedy yeah if
you're me like and we just want to be
treated as normal people no I mean like
right I quit right like quit harassing
us and talking down on us once you guys
help us out like why don't you guys you
for me like help us make a step give us
that ride to probation and parole so we
don't end up in jail well we have to
completely change the system I say the
only way to really fix that is to just
really um the system the whole system
needs to change you know with the
epidemic of all that's happened right
I dare to be honest like when I first
met you I don't you I have my out of my
homies even me like two days out of the
week those blue shirts that you should
come clean the alley they don't even
clean really
much anymore but like Wednesdays and
Thursdays
I'll make them sit down you can me I'll
give him 20 bucks to eat a lunch go go
bye go get some lunch we'll clean Ally
we live here in these alleys yeah we're
like it not all of us like if we [ __ ] it
up it's gonna get cleaned in the morning
for sure I mean like people don't walk
like some people just don't give a [ __ ]
even me but not everybody's like that 19
night like not even half of everybody's
like that yeah it's always just like a
3% yeah there's the room the image yeah
for other people that are just trying to
make it yeah I asked this question on
the show George do I want to know what
you think about it what do you thinks
the most beautiful thing in the world
most beautiful thing in the world Wow my
ex-wife no no most beautiful thing in
the world would be Brett I guess air
look through everything in the world be
the world I guess I'm not a high powered
5% or nothing like that it's I guess
living thing in the world these are real
good breath world living yeah ex-wife I
mean that's one thing that's messed me
up a lot is that it's my divorce we're
talk about that later
juju I got you a link in the bio for go
phone me I'm and make that page we're
gonna set you up with that hopefully get
people to contribute and then and then
I'll all linked up with juju and get you
the the funding for that as soon as
possible
juju this has been I don't even know I
don't even ought to say it's raw
you know it's raw it's real it's you you
know and I wish I could've told you more
or told my I told you a lot well well
bring him back we'll have you back juju
is mortified do you know see what we can
do with turning someone's life around
please stay with us stay with us
let's make it happen let's get you into
the situation where you can throw the
keys on the table and you can say like I
just like I loved my life in town with
my life like that
I want to write a book yeah I don't know
that is yourself to do it and do it we
write a book promise yourself to do it
and do it those are the big things that
you can do in life set those goals Thank
You Julian thank you for coming on
really appreciate it thanks everybody
for tuning in this has been a hugely
emotional episode and a serious episode
about what we can do to change things
and those things around please go check
out the link in the bio to Judy's
GoFundMe page let's get that role and as
soon as possible everyone thank you so
much for tuning in thanks Ron for
producing and directing much love
everyone we'll see you soon
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]